good morning Hank it's Sunday May 3rd
two days before your birthday and as you
can tell from the great speckled wall
behind me I'm in an airport fancy that
so Hank today I'm going to talk about
swine flu panic but before I do that I
want to talk about me and you mostly me
nerdfighters if you wanted to go to the
event in Melbourne Australia but you
couldn't get a ticket good news there's
a second event linked in the sidebar and
also I'm going to be in Sydney on June
3rd secondly Hank as you know on
Thursday night my book Paper Towns won
an Edgar Award an award given out by the
Mystery Writers of America to the best
mystery novels of the year Hank this
means that I now own a bust of Edgar
Allan Poe that's right
I own a bust so nerdfighters I need your
help please answer the following
question for me in comments what can you
do with a bust of Edgar Allen Poe what
can you do with a Poe bust oh and Hank
about you your birthday is on Tuesday
I'm gonna get you a little something
hopefully nerdfighters you'll make some
videos and do some stuff as well please
do not ask for my attention right now
so Hank here's a little-known fact about
me I am somewhat terrified of new and
strange diseases I think it's because
when I was in college I had to fulfill a
science requirement so I took a class
called aids Ebola and emerging viruses
because it was purportedly easy and it
was kind of easy but the downside was
that I learned about AIDS Ebola and
emerging viruses which are just not
topics that hypochondriac should be
exposed to anyway Hank you can imagine
my dismay when the news broke about h1n1
flu or swine flu or ointment
I think oink barf is its technical name
here was this flu in Mexico traveling
easily between people killing 10% of its
victims most of whom worked between 25
and 45 Hank I find it alarming when
people between 25 and 45 died of flu
first off because that's the same thing
that happened during the pandemic of
1918 which killed more people than all
of World War two and secondly because
Hank I don't know if you've noticed this
but it so happens that I am between 25
and 45 so of course I was extremely
alarmed but then since then it turns out
that people may have been slightly
overreacting for instance it appears
that Point Park does not kill 10% of its
victims but closer to 1% and also it
appears to kill not just those between
25 and 45 but you know just people
generally now think I'm not gonna lie to
you I'm still a little bit terrified of
1/4
fact that's probably why I'm calling it
wink ARF but what interests me is why
we're all so afraid of it
I mean obviously there's the fact that
if 10% of people who got it actually
required hospitalization we would let
run out of hospital beds in short order
and everyone would freak out but my
suspicion is that our fear of pandemic
goes deeper than that
what pandemic forces us to think about
is the fact that not only am I going to
die and you're going to die but
everyone's going to die and in fact
there will come a time when there are no
human beings left to remember that there
were ever human beings which is I'm
willing to acknowledge a little bit
alarming thank s scott Fitzgerald
famously wrote that the test of a
first-rate intelligence is the ability
to hold two opposing ideas in the mind
at the same time in that same essay he
wrote I must hold and balance the sense
of the futility of effort and the sense
of the necessity to struggle but in
general the way that we respond to the
futility of effort is by you know
ignoring it so I just don't think about
the fact that some day no one will read
Shakespeare let alone my books even
though it is an Edgar Award winner I
don't think pandemics make us afraid of
death I think they make us afraid of
oblivion they force us to grapple with
the futility of effort also they make us
barf which isn't fun either
hey nerdfighters wash your hands cover
your coughs and find a way to hold and
balance the futility of effort with the
necessity to struggle Hank I for one I'm
gonna keep struggling on ergo you'll see
me on Tuesday